we will now continue on with our um with
our instruction or our lectures on on
third grade singapore math and what i
really like about this this whole
singapore math way of teaching is that
they start with fairly simple concepts
but they really make sure that you have
a deep deep deep understanding of what
the concepts what the concept is and all
the different ways to think about it so
for example today i'm going to start
talking about addition and subtraction
you might say well i already know how to
add and subtract and you probably do and
maybe you'll find this
easy but
i think you'll find that if as we go
through all of the lectures you might
discover some new insights or some new
ways of looking at something that you
thought was really really really easy so
let's say that i wanted to know well
well first of all you know about
addition and subtraction right if i say
i wanted to add one and two you would
say well that's just one plus two
that equals three
and i'm going to introduce you to what
could be a new word or actually two new
words and that's sum and difference
so the sum is essentially
when you say to find the sum of two
numbers you're essentially adding them
and when you say the difference you're
essentially saying how different are the
two numbers and i'll give you a bunch of
examples
let me
so let's say
i have in the singapore math book i'm
actually on page 18 and i'm just using
their problems i'm doing a few
adaptations uh this is the the this is
the this is the 3a primary mathematics
book
but i'll do some adaptations for the
most part i'm just doing their problems
and with a little bit of uh my
commentary
so let's say i had four they draw
flowers but let's say i just have four
circles
and i have seven circles right below it
one two three four
five
six seven
and our question is
what is the sum
what is
the sum
of
four
and
seven well i just said taking the sum of
two numbers is just like adding the two
numbers so taking the sum of four and
seven is the same thing as taking the
sum of seven and four and of course if
we're just going to add the two numbers
we just have to know what four plus
seven is
and you
should hopefully know that offhand if
you don't
you can count these circles up here 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11. all right the sum
is essentially
how much do we have when we combine the
two numbers or the sum
now what if i were to ask you
what
is
the difference
between
between and that's kind of an important
and important word between four and
seven
so as i said a difference tells you
when someone's asking what's the
difference they want to know how
different are the two numbers
so how different are 4 this is 4 up here
this is 4 up here
and this is 7. how different are 4 and 7
well there's a there's
four would be seven if it had three more
right
if we if we drew three if four was three
larger it would be the same thing as
seven
so when someone is is saying what is the
difference between four and seven
they're literally asking you
how much do you have to increase the the
smaller number to get the bigger number
or how much you could also say well to
get from seven to four i have to take
three out of seven
but either way you look at it the
difference between the two is three and
how do you calculate it well you
subtract the smaller number from the
larger number so you say seven
minus four
is equal to three and that three is the
difference between the two you could
view it as how much do you have to
increase the smaller number to get the
bigger number or how much do you have to
decrease the bigger number to get the
smaller number or just you know how big
is the i don't want to use the same word
but you know how how different are they
anyway i don't want to be the dead horse
as they say
so let me draw
some
some cubes singapore matte style
so they draw
eight cubes let's see i'm going to try
to approximate i'll do it in a slightly
different color they only use two colors
throughout the whole book
let me see well that's not what i wanted
to do but good enough
let's see they want to do eight so let
me drive it divided in 2 first
let's see that's about the middle
and then if i divide it in 2 again here
and here that will be 4. then i have to
divide each of these and do to get 8.
that's because i wanted them to be
relatively so that's eight and then they
have five and so five
i'll use a different color for five
let's see but i wanted to e match up so
it's one two three four
five
and i will let me split it up
so you get
one
two
three
four
and so
they wanna they they tell us well you
know
eight plus five oh that's i'm using the
eight plus five is equal to and they say
blank
well we're just adding the two numbers
you might not know it already but you
should visualize it well it's eight plus
five it's like if you took these and you
put them at this end right here how many
how would be the total length of the
longer bar or what is the combined
length of the two bars right 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
right and you probably find that really
really really easy but the reason why
they're doing that is so that you
realize how the sum is different from
the difference so for example you know
we could have rewritten this statement
as
the sum
of eight
and five
is thirteen
and what my phone's ringing
and i'm not gonna answer it
i think i think that's someone getting
me to either donate money or
buy dish networks or or whatever
so now let's do let me you know this is
the sum that's the easy part now what
what would you say if i asked you what
is the difference
what
is
the difference
what is the difference
between
eight and 13. and i could have said it
either way and that's where
writing it as the difference as opposed
to subtracting is different if i could
have said what is the difference between
13 and 8 either way it doesn't matter we
just want to know
how far oh sorry not between 8 and 13. i
want to know the difference actually
although that's an interesting question
to answer as well but what is the
difference between eight and five
eight and five
right what is the difference between
eight and five how so
how far apart are they essentially well
if we look here if we have these this
blue five if we added three more cubes
we would get eight or if we took these
three cubes off of the eight we would
have gotten five so either way you would
have to change one of the numbers by
three to get the other one right so the
difference between eight and five is the
same thing as
eight minus five
which is equal to
three
hopefully you're getting the hang of it
and actually even more important than
just being able to do the problem
because i think you find this type of
problem to be extremely easy or this
type of problem to be extremely easy i
want you to understand
kind of on a deeper level what it's
really saying it's saying how far apart
are these numbers it just doesn't want
you to say oh well i've already
memorized what eight and five are uh it
what the what you know eight minus five
is it wants you to really we really want
you to think about but it's just saying
how how how different are the two
numbers
you literally can just read the sentence
literally that's all it means
so let's say that i had two bars
i'm not going to break them up anymore
let's say that the length of this bar
is i don't know it's 90.
maybe it's 90 millimeters maybe it's 90
miles
who knows the length of that bar is 90.
and let's say that i have another bar
right here
let me turn my phone ringer back on my
i had it off the other day when i was
recording these videos and my wife
called and she couldn't get me and
she questioned whether i cared about her
anymore so it's very important when
loved ones call that you pick up the
phone anyway back to back to the math
problem
um what was i doing
so i had another bar right here
and let's say the length of that bar
let's say the length of this bar
is 54.
so i will ask you the same questions
that we've been asking this entire video
what
is
the
sum
of 90
and 54.
and i'm also going to ask you what is
what is
the difference the hardest part of these
problems is probably reading my
handwriting what is the difference
between
90
and 54.
well once again the sum they're saying
well what happens when you combine these
two blocks if i put this block here
and i could do that let me see
if i put that block here
you would get a
it would add on over here roughly about
that long
and so you want the sum you want the
length of the entire thing
and hopefully you know how to add two
numbers but if you don't we can work it
out it's 54 plus 90. so let's do 90
plus 54.
0 plus 4 is 4
5 plus 9 is 14.
144 which also is 12 times 12 but anyway
i'm getting off topic
anyway the sum of 90 and 54 is 90 plus
54 which is 144
and then what is the difference between
90 and 54. now this is i think where it
gets a little bit more conceptually easy
interesting
when you think about difference you want
to know how far apart are the two
numbers or what would i have to add to
54 to get 90 or what would i have to
take
to subtract from 90 to get to 54. either
of those
is the difference
and so we could just say 90 minus 54
right the way to calculate the
difference is to subtract the smaller
from the larger number
we could say 90 minus 54.
and we're going to do this might be a
little bit of a review from second grade
but
we could you should hope actually it's
not a bad idea to memorize it and i'll
i'll give you a way to think about it
what's the difference between 60 and 54
the difference
54 is six away from 60 right
and what's the difference 90 and 60.
sorry the difference let me let me say
it this way i'm running out of space the
90
minus 60 is equal to 30 right
and 60
minus 54
is equal to 6.
so 90 minus 54 is actually 36.
that's how i do it in my head and i get
a little bit off the singapore math
curriculum but maybe maybe you'll find
something like that interesting but the
other way to do it and we'll we'll go
into more detail in in in terms of how
does borrowing or regrouping work
but you could say
90
minus 54.
and this is just classic borrowing
we could say well let me borrow a 10
let me borrow one from the tens place
and that becomes 10 in the ones place
right
just going back to our place value so we
took you know we essentially cashed in a
a ten dollar chip and got ten one dollar
chips and then we take that ten minus
the four is six and then
eight minus five is thirty six so either
way the difference between ninety and
fifty four
is thirty six and now this is
interesting what is the difference
what is different what
is
the difference
between
90
and 36
so what would you have to add to 36 to
get 90 or what would you have to
subtract from 90 to get 36 well let me
give you a hint
we know the difference between 90 and 54
is 36. if i drew a block here of exactly
length 36 it would look something like
this
right that is of
not in my drawing but in the idea that
is of length 36.
so there's a couple of ways we can think
about it the difference between 54 and
90 is 36 that's how that's how much one
would have to grow or one would have to
shrink or the difference between 19 and
54 is 36
the sum of 54 and 36 is 90
right
and also the difference between 90 and
36 is 54. and why is that because
imagine if this wasn't here and we were
we just had that question was it what is
the difference between 90 and 36 well we
could say well we could increase 36 by
54 to the left to get 90 or we could
decrease 90 by 54 to the right to get
36. well anyway hopefully you found this
vaguely insightful and i did not either
bore or confuse you and i will see you
in the next video see you soon